Donald Trump is trying to find
a replacement for Obamacare,
probably one where
I'm gonna guess
cancer patients are prescribed
a round of golf
and a visit
to a strip-club buffet.
-(laughter) -But it's proving
to be tougher than he thought.
Take a look.
Now, I have to tell you it's an
unbelievably complex subject.
Nobody knew that health care
could be so complicated.
-(laughter)
-Nobody knew.
No one had any (bleep) idea.
It was a total out of the blue.
We got sideswiped with
the complexity of health care.
Our favorite reaction
to the president's
"bewilderness" came from
Bernie Sanders
who did this on CNN. "Ah!"
(laughter)
(applause and cheering)
I don't know if you guys
are gonna get this reference,
but this reminds me
of the preacher
from Poltergeist II.
-Ha, ha! You're all gonna die!
-(laughter, applause & cheering)
By the way,
Bernie looks great.
So much color in his face!
He looks like
a beautiful little strawberry
that got caught in a spider web.
Comedians, what's the last thing
that made Bernie laugh
like this?
-Henry.
-Chris, I want to correct you.
He's not actually laughing.
He's having a heart attack.
-All right, yeah. Points. Yeah.
-(laughter and groaning)
I'm sorry. He's right.
He might be right. Angela.
When he remembers
he can get rock hard erections.
-HARDWICK: All right, points.
Yeah. -(laughter, cheering)
(laughter)
-He can.
-HARDWICK: I was not expecting
the space work
right after that.
That caught me by surprise.
Points. Brendon.
When he successfully
sent Marty home
by harnessing a lightning bolt.
HARDWICK:
All right, points. Yeah.
-(laughter, applause & cheering)
-Oh!
82.2 gigawatts.
HARDWICK:
No, it's, uh...
"1.21 jigawatts. 1.21.
-1.21 jigawatts."
-(laughter)